i've got peanut butter on the bed
[Music]
hey i'm anne-marie and i'm here having
breakfast in bed with tasty my perfect
breakfast
is toast because the smell puts me in a
good mood and i love peanut butter so i
have to have peanut butter and butter
the toast has to be like
lightly browned and then i put the
butter on and then the peanut butter
i have a cup of tea it has to be
english breakfast tea i have my tea with
almond milk and
it has to be quite light
so quite a lot of milk and sugar loads
of sugar sometimes i like to dip my
toast in my tea even with the peanut
butter
yeah with peanut butter in the tea if
you you have to try it i know everyone
is going to be listening like
but please try it
i just started drinking green juices in
the morning actually throughout the
whole day just because it it tastes so
good now
this looks like heaven
and i've actually
i ate my first blackberry
like last
august
and now i love them
kind of warm on the outside
i feel like i'm at home
when i put the butter on it has to reach
every corner because i eat the whole
thing and i don't want to get to the
edge
of like the crust and there'd be no
butter there
so that really annoys me when people do
that how did we do you did really well
i've inspected it already
my dad is the cook in the house and he
loves cooking but i never used to like
anything so whenever
we got home from school my dad would
have cooked us all dinner and i'd just
be eating a philadelphia cheese sandwich
every single day i've been touring for a
long time even before my album came out
but since my album came out it's got
even better because
i guess everyone knows
all the songs because i was performing
them before but they only kind of knew
the singles and since releasing my album
has just been the best ever
pancakes are french chest
oh
oh
french toast sweet or savory sweet
coffee or tea tea
apples or bananas
bananas
peanut butter or jelly
peanut butter pineapple belong on pizza
i don't think so
i'm trying to figure that out though i
keep trying it to see
zucchini yeah
what is it in english
courgette yeah i knew that
cookie
[Music]
oh this is a weird one
uh
so this is rocket at home but it's
arugula or something
shut up did i say it right
arugula
chip fries
which is so weird to me
cotton candy so i'll just learn that the
other day
tomato
[Laughter]
you say tomato i say tomato
is this parsley
is it um i don't know but i hate this
whatever this is i hate it cilantro
cilantro
cilantro
cilantro
you're so extra
is this the emoji
you couldn't find a real one
this here is called eggplant wow i did
well there i thought i was gonna be so
bad at that
should i dip this in my tea so you get a
shot of that
oh can't fit
oh it's tripping
my favor
i think that might be my favorite thing
in the whole world i'm anne-marie and
i've just had breakfast in bed with
tasty
and i don't want to leave it
but i have to go
[Music]
[Music]
you